OK, let's let's dive into this.
We're looking at a session log
today that honestly, it feels
less like your standard fantasy
quest and, well, more like a
survival thriller.
A real pressure cooker.
It really does.
It's intense.
We're tracking this group, these
adventurers trying to tackle
Arjen Vossholt.
Yeah, the system with a pruing
manner, right?
They were told it might be, you
know, shelter.
Might be shelter.
Yeah, keywords there, because
what they actually found was,
well, just pure danger almost
from step one.
Absolutely, and that's why the
source log is so valuable.
I think it's a fantastic study.
In like extremes, you see these
characters push right to the
edge, almost immediately.
Pushed how?
Well, brink of survival stuff.
Literally within minutes of
getting inside.
They're forced to adapt, change
tactics under insane pressure.
And yeah, they do get something
out of it in the end.
Some resources.
The cost?
Exactly.
The cost is just staggering,
almost unacceptable, you could
argue emotionally, physically.
So this dive, it's like a
shortcut really to understanding
deep level strategy, resource
management when everything hits
the fan.
OK, so our mission here is to
really unpack what happened in
our guideball stall.
We're following four
adventurers.
Your horn, Tenpenny.
He's the halfling beast master.
Radley, the human Eldritch
Knight tracks a door. 1/2 Elf
Cleric of Light and Dermont
Cobain who's an elf Arcane
Trickster.
A pretty diverse group skill
wise.
Definitely.
And this isn't their first Robeo
at arguing vos Holt, is it?
They tried before.
No, they got hammered before.
Wait.
Battered by the manor's main
defenders, these revenants.
Really nasty undead.
They had to pull back.
So they've regrouped, maybe
healed up a bit, but they're
going back in that
determination.
That's kind of the core here,
isn't it?
It really is.
That's the engine driving this
whole session.
They know the risks now.
They've seen the outside.
They poked around the main hall,
the dining room, the Chapel on
that first disastrous trip.
So they know the front door is
bad news.
Exactly.
The main entrance is basically a
death trap guarded by those
revenants.
So this time they're looking for
another way in a flank.
Their plan is to reenter through
the South side, through the
ruins of this old ballroom,
trying to bypass the main
threat.
All right, let's start the clock
right there.
Their second attempt, first
floor ruined ballroom.
Because this is where it all
goes wrong.
Like instantly.
It shows how even a tiny pause,
a moment of hesitation, boom,
disaster.
Yeah, the perils of caution is
the section title suggests it's
ironic, isn't?
It OK, so they breached the
ballroom and it's just chaos,
right?
Rubble everywhere.
The goal is clear though.
Three sets of double doors on
the N wall.
That's they're way deeper into
the Manor.
Right.
And most of the party, they get
the memo.
Move fast.
Your horn, Traxidor, Dermannen,
Ranger, cleric, rogue.
They don't hang about.
No, they're quick darting
through the rubble, heading
straight for those doors.
The priority is clear.
Get out of this big, open,
exposed space.
Makes sense?
And this is the first big lesson
for you listening right now,
Radley hesitates.
Radley, the Eldridge Knight.
He just pauses.
The log suggests he's trying to
pick the safest path through the
debris.
You know, looking for stable
footing.
Which sounds sensible.
Caution seems smart.
In a normal situation, maybe,
but here it's what we call
paralysis by analysis.
Almost textbook.
In a stable place, sure, take
your time.
But this is Arjun Mostel.
High alert, hostile territory.
So the pause was bad.
Catastrophic.
Yeah, because that ballroom
floor is huge and ruined any
movement, especially lingering
movement, shifting debris.
It's like ringing a dinner bell
for whatever defenses are
lurking.
So wait, if he'd just run with
the others?
You probably would have been
fine.
The source log really points to
this.
The spiders.
These 9 enormous spiders.
And we need to stress enormous
like horse size.
Exactly.
Horse size spiders.
The log suggests they weren't
triggered by the party entering,
but by the movement of the
others passing by Radley.
Because he stopped, he's left
behind isolated.
He becomes the target.
The danger literally drops down
around the one guy who stopped
moving.
Yeah, 9 massive spiders
descending on these thick Roby
cobwebs.
Just Boo dropping from the
ceiling, converging right on
him.
It's a perfectly executed ambush
focus fire designed purely to
cut the night off from his
friends.
Nightmare fuel like you said,
and their first move isn't just
biting.
Not primarily, no.
The immediate threat is
immobilization.
They cut him off mandible
snapping yes, but they're also
trying to web him up instantly.
Gooey silk everywhere, isolate
him, then go for the kill with
poison.
Standard spider tactics just
scaled up horribly.
So Radley's trapped, cut off
spiders everywhere.
What does he do?
His night training sword and
shield.
Actually, no, not initially.
He goes for magic raw power.
Which spell he casts?
Thunder Wave.
Now Thunder Wave for anyone not
familiar.
Does OK damage sure, but its
main thing is force a big Sonic
boom that pushes things away.
So he's not trying to kill them
all at once.
Nope, he's trying to make space
create an escape route.
Tactical magic one O 1 right
there.
He needs out of that kill box.
Does that work?
It does the force of the spell,
it actually knocks stones loose
from the walls, it's that
powerful.
And critically, it blasts
several spiders backwards.
Just physically shoves them
away.
Clearing a path.
Exactly.
Just for a moment, a brief
corridor opens up towards those
double doors where his friends
went.
He doesn't hesitate now.
He bolts forward, running for
the doors, knowing full well his
back is completely exposed as
spiders are leaping at him.
And the others?
Your horn tracks the door,
Derman.
They made it through the door
safely.
Yeah, but then they hear it.
That massive boom, the Thunder
wave.
They instantly know Radley's in
deep trouble, so they turn right
back around.
Got to help their friend.
And now it's just a messy close
quarters fight in the doorway.
Incredibly chaotic.
They see Radley sprinting
towards them.
He's already hurt.
Bitten at least once.
Your horn and Derman start
firing arrows trying to cover
him.
Tracksuit or get Sacred Flame
off.
Summons his spiritual weapon.
This floating magic weapon he
controls?
Sounds like a solid counter
attack.
It should be, but the panic, the
stress.
You've got 9 giant spiders.
Your friend is near death.
It leads to a critical mistake,
a breakdown.
The friendly fire incident.
Yeah, let's focus on this
because it really shows how
things fall apart under
pressure.
Right, your horn.
The Ranger, he decides to go
big.
He tries to cast hail of thorns.
It's this spell that makes his
arrow explode into, well, a hail
of magical thorns.
Great for hitting lots of
enemies packed together.
Like the spiders around Radley.
Exactly.
He's desperate to clear them off
his friend, but in the chaos,
the spray of thorns, it hits
Radley too.
Oh no, so the rescue attempt
actually hurts the person
they're trying to save?
How do they even process that
mid fight?
It's a shock for Yurihorn.
It forces an instant rethink.
He realizes, OK, big area
attacks are too dangerous right
now.
Radley's too close.
It's a hard lesson learned on
the fly rescuing someone in
melee.
Precision beats raw power.
So your horn has to hold back
his best crowd control.
Yeah, it limits their options
for dealing with the remaining
spiders quickly.
Meanwhile, Bradley still
fighting like mad, slashing with
a sword, but he gets bitten
again and again.
The poison is building up.
Even with everyone fighting, the
spiders are relentless.
They are.
And Radley, he makes it.
He actually reaches the doors,
the threshold of safety.
But just as he gets there, a
final stream of spider silk hits
him.
He's entangled, struggling, and
the poison just overwhelms them.
Total system shock.
He collapses.
The log uses this incredibly
vivid description.
He goes down like an abandoned
marionette, just gone, right
there in the webs.
Wow, that image, it's not just
unconscious, it's complete
collapse.
Functionally dead like you said,
the poison one for.
The moment yes, and the team
immediately has to switch gears,
get the spiders for a second.
It's about triage.
Desperate high speed triage.
So the rescue you're a horn and
dermone run out.
Cut him free from the webs.
Drag him back into the relative
safety of the main hall.
Well, tracks the door.
The cleric gets to work.
He hits him with Spare the Dying
first.
What does that do exactly?
Is it a heel?
Not quite.
Think of it as emergency
stabilization.
It stops you from dying like
right now.
Stops the death saving throws.
If you know the mechanics, it
buys time crucial seconds, but
it doesn't restore hit points.
OK, so it stops the dying, then
what?
Then you're a horn follows up.
He uses a charge from a wand,
cast cure wounds, trying to
actually bring Radley back, mend
the damage.
And does it work?
It seems to Radley stabilized,
maybe starting to cough, sputter
back towards consciousness.
They must have felt this huge
wave of relief just for a
second.
A very short second, because
Arden Bostole isn't done with
Radley yet, is it?
Not even close.
Yeah, just as they think they've
saved him, one of those giant
spiders, maybe the one that
webbed him, It's not giving up.
It pushes through the doorway
into the hall.
And goes straight for Radley
again.
Straight for Radley bites him
again just as he's coming
around.
Can you imagine near death saved
and then bam the same threat
attacks again instantly.
It shows how focused these
things were on him.
That's.
Brutal.
Do they kill the spider?
Oh yeah, you're a horn and
Derman take it down fast, but
the damage is done.
Radley's taken another massive
dose of poison, tracks the door,
rushes over, cast Cure Wounds
again, and the log notes he's
genuinely scared.
It's too late this time.
Radley seems to have stopped
breathing entirely.
But the spell works.
It does a final miracle.
Radley sputters, gasps, comes
back to life again.
The relief must have been
immense, but also terrifying.
How many times can they pull him
back from the brink?
So the immediate thread is gone,
the spider's dead, the others
seem to have backed off.
What now?
Now regrouping, real regrouping,
once they're sure the coast is
clear, tracks or does something
important.
He uses a much slower, more
powerful healing spell, Prayer
of Healing.
Why that one now?
Why not more Cure Wounds?
Because prayer of healing isn't
about patching one critical
wound.
It takes 10 minutes to cast.
It's a ritual and it heals
multiple people significantly.
It's about collective recovery.
So it's not just about Radley's
hit points anymore.
Exactly.
The whole party is shaping.
Physically hurt, yeah, but also
psychologically battered.
That friendly fire, Radley
collapsing twice.
Prayer of healing is deliberate.
Pause, it says.
OK, the immediate crisis is
over, let's reset mentally and
physically.
It's restoring morale as much as
health.
Makes sense.
So they're healed up somewhat
but clearly traumatized.
What's the next move?
Because the first floor seems
like a death trap.
Your horn makes the call.
The Ranger, he basically says,
look, the north side of this
floor where we just came from is
Suicide Alley.
Let's try upstairs.
Avoid the spiders.
Avoid maybe whatever else is
lurking down there.
Smart.
And, he adds, another layer of
smart.
He remembers the other major
threat from their first visit,
the one that drove them out last
time.
The Revenants.
Those relentless undead patrols.
Precisely.
They know those things wander
the Manor, probably including
this main hall they're resting
in.
So Yuri Horn doesn't wait to
bump into them, he acts
preemptively.
He cast Pass without a trace.
It's a fantastic group stealth
spell, makes everyone incredibly
hard to detect.
It's not just reacting to danger
anymore, it's anticipating the
known threat and actively
mitigating it.
They're choosing calculated
stealth over just hoping the
revenants don't show up.
A much better plan than just
standing still.
OK, so with Pass Without a Trace
active, they head for the grand
staircase.
The scent goes smoothly then.
No revenant patrols.
Seems like it the spell works.
They make it to the second floor
and start exploring the north
wing, which looks more intact.
More like, you know, actual
living quarters Once Upon a
time.
First stop, bedroom one.
What's it like?
It feels like a nobles room
definitely, but creepy
obviously.
Everything draped in cobwebs,
curtain covered windows, there's
a big black marble fireplace and
the log mentions a great view
looking out of the valley in
this ruined dragon statue
outside.
Lots of environmental detail
and.
The portrait that sounds
important.
Yeah, above the fireplace, a
framed portrait.
Handsome guy, looks wealthy,
dressed well, but the key thing,
the log notes, is his
expression.
A wry smile and he's got this
thick mane of Thistle down hair.
A wry smile that tells you
something about his personality,
doesn't it?
Confident, maybe.
Arrogant.
Exactly.
In a place like this, dripping
with history and tragedy, who is
this guy?
Is he the former Lord of the
Manor?
Is he connected to the
revenants?
That portrait isn't just
decoration, it's a clue.
It adds a layer of personality
to the place.
They're not just fighting random
monsters, they're in a place
with a specific, maybe unhappy,
history.
They also note some other
details.
Dragon carvings on the bedposts.
Yeah, it ties into the dragon
statue outside.
Maybe the name Arjun Vossholt
itself here.
Rotting mattress, obviously
large wardrobe that's just empty
inside, like someone cleared out
in a hurry, or maybe something
valuable used to be hidden
there.
And a single.
Chair facing the fireplace, like
someone used to sit there and
think or brood, right?
These little domestic touches,
they make the danger feel more
jarring when it comes.
And Speaking of jarring, just as
they're taking all this in, they
hear something weird.
What's that?
The sound of a wagon outside
arriving at the Manor.
A wagon.
Now that's odd.
Do they investigate?
Nope.
It's a distraction, but they
make a conscious choice.
Ignore it, focus on the mission
inside, which honestly, is
probably another smart tactical
move.
Don't get sidetracked by
unknowns when you have a clear
objective inside a dangerous
place.
OK, so they stick.
To the plan, move on to bedroom
two across the hall.
What's this one like?
Is this grand?
Two canopy beds, but the fabric
is tattered.
Faded rug.
Another fireplace, this one
really sooty, but it's not the
look of the room that stopped
them, it's the sound.
What are they here?
A soft hissing, like a snake
coming from the fireplace.
Uh oh.
After the giant spiders, a
hissing sound is probably not
welcome.
Not at all.
And this is where you see the
direct impact of that first
floor trauma.
The log is super clear about
this because of Radley's near
death experience with the
spiders.
They're just terrified of
another ambush, another
potentially debilitating
encounter.
So they don't.
Even peek, don't throw something
in nothing.
They just back away immediately.
No investigation.
It's pure risk assessment driven
by fear and resource management.
Meaning they know tracksidors
already burned through major
healing spells saving Radley.
They can't afford another fight
that takes someone out, forces
them to use up their last
reserves.
It's not about being scared of a
little snake.
It's about being scared of being
unprepared for what might
follow.
The fear of losing control
overrides any curiosity.
They decide this encounter isn't
necessary, so they avoid it.
OK.
Sensible if cautious, they keep
moving down.
The hallway.
It leads to an east West
corridor, windows facing north,
and at the ends, 2 doors,
presumably leading into the
manor's turrets.
Your horn tries the western door
first.
It's stuck, doesn't budget, and
as he's fiddling with it, that's
when the trap springs.
What kind of?
Trap the whole way they.
Came in, seals up solid wall of
stone just materializes.
Blocks the corridor exit
completely.
They're trapped, boxed in.
Whoa.
Not a pressure plate, just
magic.
Pure magic.
And the moment the wall slams
shut, the manor's second floor
defense kicks in.
Encounter 2 begins.
What is it this time?
More spiders?
Nope.
Ghosts.
Spectral soldiers.
They just materialize right
through the walls, described as
malevolent, and glide forward to
attack.
OK, so first.
Floor physical threat, Poison
webs.
Second floor magical trap.
Ethereal attackers.
Big difference.
Huge difference.
And they know immediately this
isn't a simple locked room
puzzle.
Dierman, the rogue, tries to
practical escape.
First, he looks at the windows
in the corridor.
Can they break?
Out.
Not easily.
They're those slotted kinds, and
the panes are reinforced with
metal.
Even if they break the glass,
the openings are too narrow to
squeeze through quickly,
especially in armor.
Escape isn't really an option,
meanwhile.
Eurohorn is frantically looking
for a switch, a lever, anything.
Yeah, he does a quick.
Search button, tripwire,
pressure plate, nothing, he
concludes.
The wall is 100% magical.
There's no physical off switch
so.
They're trapped.
Ghosts are attacking.
How does the fight go?
What do they learn about these
spectral soldiers?
Two things.
Very quickly, and both are bad
news.
First, even though the soldiers
are ghosts, they're swords.
Totally solid when they hit you.
Sharp is real steel.
They cut through armor, hurt
just like a normal weapon.
OK, so they can.
Hurt the party?
Can the party hurt them back?
That's the.
Second lesson, and it's worse.
Physical weapons, swords,
arrows, they just pass right
through the ghosts.
Mostly ineffective.
Maybe a tiny bit of damage, but
not nearly enough.
A fighter relying purely on
muscle and steel would be almost
useless here.
So conventional.
Tactics are out.
What do they do?
This is where.
Tracidor, the Cleric of Light,
becomes absolutely essential.
He sees physical attacks aren't
working, so he pivots completely
changes the strategy.
He uses his connection to his
deity.
He channels divinity,
specifically the power to turn
undead.
Now, this isn't like a fireball
spell that just does damage.
It's an assertion of divine
authority, his God's power
flowing through him, directly
challenging the unholy nature of
the ghosts.
It's about forcing them to flee
through spiritual power, not
hurting them physically and does
that.
Work.
Oh, it works.
Spectacularly, instantly, almost
all the phantom soldiers recoil.
They're compelled to flee by the
divine power.
All except one.
Wow, So the.
Cleric basically ended the fight
with one move pretty much.
Neutralized the main threat.
But even in that moment of
victory, you see the stress and
maybe the lingering panic from
the spider fight.
What happens?
Derman and Radley, they
instinctively start swinging
their weapons or maybe shooting
arrows at the ghosts that are
fleeing.
Oh, is that bad?
It can be.
Track store actually has to yell
at them mid combat.
Basically stop, don't attack
them.
He explains quickly that
attacking undead who have been
turned can break the compulsion.
They can snap them out of it so
they.
Almost undid their own victory
by acting on instinct.
Exactly.
He had to give them a rapid fire
lesson on the rules of
engagement for turned undead
right there in the corridor.
If they'd broken the turning
effect, all those ghosts would
have swarmed back and the party
low on effective attacks would
have been in serious trouble.
Shows how crucial understanding
your abilities and their limits
is.
OK, so they.
Hold back.
The ghosts flee.
What about the one that wasn't
turned?
That one they can.
Focus on since physical weapons
aren't great.
Radley uses his magic.
Probably fire bolt or something
similar that affects ethereal
creatures.
Trackstore likely uses spells
too.
They take down the last ghost.
Fights over, but they're still
trapped, right?
The Stonewall is still there,
Stiller.
Solid as ever, the magical trap
remains, even though the ghostly
Guardians are gone, so the focus
shifts back from magic to the
physical world.
Specifically, those turret
doors, the ones you're.
A horn couldn't open earlier,
right?
Derriman pulls out his thieves
tools, gives him a proper check.
His conclusion?
They're not locked in the
traditional sense.
No tumblers to pick.
They must be stuck shut, or
maybe barred from the other
side, physically blocked.
So after.
A fight decided by magic and
faith.
They need brute force.
Exactly.
It's this great contrast.
Magic got them into this mess,
Magic got them through the
fight, but now they need good
old fashioned muscle to get out.
And who's got?
The muscle Radley.
The guy described as having
tremendous physical strength,
the same guy who was on death's
door just what, an hour ago?
He steps up to one of the turret
doors, sets his shoulder against
it, and just shoves.
With a loud.
Splintering crack, yes.
He forces the door open.
It's this really visceral
moment, right?
Physical power overcoming the
obstacle after all the magic and
spirits, really satisfying.
So they get into.
The turret rooms, both of them,
yeah, they force the other.
One open too, and inside, well,
they look like old barracks
rooms.
Total mess.
Tattered curtains, torch sconces
ripped from the walls, bunk beds
smashed to pieces, empty weapons
racks clearly long abandoned.
Probably saw some fighting back
in the day.
Just ruins.
Then no reward for all that
trouble.
But there is hidden amongst all
the debris in the western turret
room tracks, the door finds
something.
A small coffer looks like it was
just forgotten, left behind ages
ago and inside.
Fresher. 4 vials.
The log describes them as
Chrysling vials of potions of
invulnerability.
Invulnerability.
Potions, that's that's huge.
That's not just a few gold
pieces.
That's a game changer for a
future fight, absolutely.
Massive find something that
could literally save their lives
down the line.
But think about what it cost to
get them.
Bradley almost died twice.
They were magically trapped,
fought ghosts, expanded spells,
dealt with friendly fire, all
for these 4 potions.
A high price.
So they grabbed the potions.
What about the magic wall
trapping them in the corridor?
Funny thing.
Once they've explored both
turret rooms and come back out,
the wall is just gone.
Vanished.
Seriously.
Just like that, yeah.
It's like the manners defense
system activated.
They dealt with the threat, the
ghosts, maybe finding the
potions was part of passing the
test, and then the trap reset
itself.
The building has this weird,
almost automated logic to it.
Very strange.
OK, so they got.
Through the ghost attack they
found these amazing potions.
The magic wall is gone.
They must be feeling pretty good
or just exhausted.
Probably mostly.
Exhausted and wary.
That phantom encounter after the
spider fiasco.
It was intense, mentally
draining, needing those quick
strategy shifts.
So the party makes a collective
decision.
Get out, get out of the mansion
again.
Who's got their prize?
Time to leave before something
else happens.
Exactly they.
Head back down, probably
checking over their shoulders
the whole way, and pause
outside.
Catch the breath and this is
where they start to really
process what just happened,
especially questioning the Intel
that got them here.
Yeah, Yuri Horn brings it up
right, questioning then Richton,
the guy who supposedly told them
this place was safe, right?
He basically.
Asks why would Van Richten call
this place safe when it's
obviously crawling with danger,
which is a very valid question
after nearly being eaten by
giant spiders and trapped by
ghosts and this?
Leads to that really interesting
discussion.
They have the difference between
shelter and safety.
That's a key take away for
anyone listening, isn't it?
Absolutely.
Critical.
They sort of speculate.
Maybe Van Richten didn't promise
safety.
Maybe he just said it was a
place they could find shelter.
Protection from the rain, from
wolves, from the general misery
of the land.
But shelter?
Doesn't mean friendly occupants
or no magical death traps.
Precisely.
It's a massive strategic lesson.
When you get intelligence,
especially from allies, you have
to parse the exact words.
What was actually promised?
What was implied, what was not
said?
Assuming shelter means safe
space was potentially fatal
assumption here.
A roof over your head doesn't
stop pore sized spiders.
OK, so.
They're outside, reflecting on
bad Intel, feeling maybe a bit
foolish, but alive.
And then things get weirder.
Remember that wagon they heard
earlier?
Oh yeah.
The wagon they decided to
ignore.
Well, now they're outside and
the wagon gone, the driver gone.
OK.
Maybe they just left.
Maybe.
But they didn't leave empty
handed.
Or rather, they left something
behind, something specific.
What is?
It right there.
On the ground near where the
wagon must have been a coffin.
A coffin.
Just sitting there, just sitting
there.
Plain wood, probably, but with
one horrifying detail.
What carved into the lid,
expertly carved the log notes,
is the name Radley Fulthorn.
Wait, Radley's.
Full name carved onto a coffin
left right outside the place he
nearly died in twice.
Exactly this.
Is this changes everything?
This isn't random manner danger
anymore, this is targeted
virtual malicious.
Who would do that?
Who even knows his full name?
And the expertly carved part
that implies skill, time,
planning.
This wasn't slapped together.
It's deeply.
Unsettling.
It shifts the threat profile
completely.
They're not just explorers
stumbling to hazards.
Now they know, or at least
Radley knows, he's being hunted.
Someone sophisticated knows who
he is, where he is, and it's
sending him a very, very clear
message.
A death.
Threat basically delivered via
coffin.
Do they do they open it?
I mean, would you the log?
Says they hesitate several
apprehensive moments, which is
completely understandable.
But yeah, eventually they do.
They open the coffin and inside.
Spiders skeleton empty.
Empty.
Completely empty.
Which is almost worse, isn't it?
Yeah, an.
Empty coffin with your name on
it?
Yeah.
It's not about a past death,
it's about a future one.
It's not a warning.
It's a reservation, a promise.
Right A.
Psychological masterstroke by
whoever left it.
Pure terror tactic.
It instills this deep paranoia.
Who was watching them?
How close are they?
Is the danger inside the Manor
or is it now waiting for them
outside too, for Radley?
Especially this must be
terrifying.
He's physically scarred from the
poison, and now he's got this,
this named dread hanging over
him.
He's marked totally.
The fear shifts from the
environment, the spiders, the
ghosts, to an intelligent,
unseen, persistent enemy.
Someone is playing a long game,
and Radley is the piece they're
focused on.
OK this.
Is a lot spiders, ghosts, near
deaths, potions, and now a
personalized coffin threat.
What does the party do?
It's only just past noon.
They make a.
Decision that speaks volumes
about their state, despite it
being broad daylight.
They decide they need to stop
right now.
They're going to make camp and
rest until next morning.
Camp.
Right outside Arjen Vasthold.
After all that, it shows how.
Utterly drained they are.
Physically, yes, but mostly
mentally and emotionally.
The cumulative stress, the
chaos, the friendly fire,
Radley's collapses, the ghost
fight, and now this chilling
coffin.
It's too much.
They cannot face another
conflict, inside or out, without
a serious break.
So it's not about.
Waiting for darkness or
strategy.
It's just burnout.
They need to shut down and
recover.
Exactly.
Resource depletion, forcing a
compromise, need to process,
regain some composure.
The emotional toll has just
wiped them out.
They can't function effectively
like this, so they set up.
Camp right there.
Do they feel safe?
Safe.
Probably not.
Wary, definitely.
They set up watches two people
on duty at all times.
They have those four amazing
potions now a huge asset, but
they've essentially traded the
known dangers inside the Manor
for the unknown potentially
personalized danger outside.
It's a calculated risk board of
sheer exhaustion.
All right, so they.
Camp through the afternoon,
through the night.
A tense, probably restless camp.
Does the night pass peacefully?
Mostly.
But they're paranoia, that
feeling of being watched.
It turns out to be justified.
Very early the next morning, day
17, just as dawn is thinking
about breaking trouble, Arise
Chairman and Traxador.
And it's chairman, the rogue
with keen eyes, who spots them
first.
Glowing eyes for approaching
from the South through the
gloom.
Glowing eyes.
Not good.
What are they?
Figures emerge.
Humanoid shape, but moving
weirdly stiffly, mechanically,
and the party recognizes them.
Not new.
Monsters then, thankfully.
No animated scarecrows.
They've fought these things
before.
Apparently on the road coming
from Valaki, which is
interesting.
Does it mean these things are
just ambient threats around our
giant Voss Holt or is it related
to the coffin?
Is there enemies sending minions
now?
Hard to.
Say, how does the attack go?
Are scarecrows tough?
They're not.
Pushovers.
They move faster than you'd
expect.
Unexpected speed, the log says.
And their main weapon besides
claws, is psychological.
They radiate this aura of
supernatural dread.
Fear.
Oh great.
So.
Just as your Horn and Radley are
scrambling out of their sleep,
they get hit with magical fear.
Exactly.
Imagine waking up to that,
especially after the day they
just had.
They're already emotionally
fragile.
The Scarecrows aren't just
attacking their bodies, they're
attacking their minds.
The resolve.
It makes the fight immediately
desperate, vicious, and it
forces them to use up the few
skull slots They probably
recovered during the rest.
So it's another.
Costly fight, even if they know
the enemy.
Very costly.
In terms of remaining resources.
But there is a moment here for
Radley, a bit of tactical
clarity, maybe even redemption
after his earlier struggles.
What does he do?
He remembers.
Or realizes that his magic,
specifically Firebolt, a simple
can trip but fiery is super
effective against scarecrows.
I mean, they're made straw and
wood right?
Makes sense?
Burn up.
And he does.
He starts setting them ablaze.
It's a smart use of his
abilities.
The perfect counter shows that
even after everything, the
trauma, the poison, the coffin,
he can still think tactically
and act decisively when it
counts.
So the fire.
Helps turn the tide big time.
The party manages to shake off
the fear effect, rally and fight
back effectively.
They take down the scarecrows.
They survive the final hurdle of
the immediate Arjun, Vos told
Area OK.
Scarecrows dealt with the sun's
coming up, maybe the first pale.
Light of dawn is showing, Yeah,
full daylight isn't quite there
yet.
They've won the fight.
But, the log notes, even after
that long rest, they feel
completed, utterly spent, that
last fight.
Even if they won, just drain the
last reserves completely.
That plus the rough camping, the
constant tension from the
coffin, it all just confirms
what they probably already knew.
They need real shelter, proper
sanctuary, not just a campsite
outside haunted house if you
connect all.
The dots, their resource pool
spells, energy, morale.
It's basically empty.
They survived Arjin, Vos, Holt,
barely.
They survived the Scarecrows,
but they can't risk another
fight like the Ballroom or The
Phantoms.
Not now, Absolutely not They.
Need a safe place, somewhere to
properly rest, maybe figure out
what to do about this coffin
situation, Plan their next move.
So what's the?
Decision back into Arjun
Bostholt is clearly not an
option.
No way.
The decision is strategic
retreat.
They decide to head east, get
back on the Mains Village Rd.
And make for a place they hope
will be safer, the Wizards of
Wine Vineyard run by the
Martakoff.
Family.
That's the one.
It's known territory, maybe
neutral ground.
At least save them where they
are now.
So this isn't.
Running away in defeat, it's a
tactical move, I'd say so.
They achieved a major objective.
They got those incredibly
valuable potions.
They gathered Intel maybe about
the manners, history and
defenses, but they also
recognized they hit their limit.
Their operational capacity was
maxed out.
Pushing further would be
suicide.
So they're.
Trading the known danger of our
John Boswell for the hope of
safety elsewhere?
Exactly.
It's a calculated withdrawal.
They break camp quickly, leave
the ominous manner behind them,
carrying their treasure, their
physical and mental scars, and
that absolutely terrifying image
of Radley's name on an empty
coffin.
Hashtag tag 506 Conclusion and
final thought.
Wow, what a session.
When you lay it all out like
that, it really is a story about
resilience isn't it?
And about adapting under fire.
They didn't just stick to 1
plan, they had to constantly
pivot.
Absolutely.
They survived not because they
were stronger than the threats,
necessarily, but because they
were adaptable.
They went from needing physical
defense against spiders, to
needing magical stealth against
revenants, to needing divine
power against ghosts, then back
to pure physical strength to
break down a door, all while
managing dwindling resources and
rising panic.
It really.
Was a master class in risk
management like you said at the
start and resource management.
Every choice had a consequence
that affected the next choice
precisely.
Radley's physical crisis with
the spiders that burned through
their critical healing magic
almost immediately.
That lack of healing then made
them more cautious, leading to
the stealth approach upstairs
which led them.
Right into the magical trap with
The Phantoms, right?
And they only survived that
because Tracidor recognized
physical attacks were useless
and instantly switched to
Channel Divinity.
Then when magic failed to open
the way out of the trap, they
needed Radley's physical
strength again.
It's all interconnected.
OK, so.
Let's distill this.
What are the big takeaways for
you, the listener, from this
whole Arjun Boss Holt ordeal
framed as like strategic
principles you can actually use?
All right, Nugget.
Number one, beware of
assumptions, especially about
safety.
Never ever confuse the word
shelter with the word safe,
especially when you're getting
Intel that whole.
Discussion about Van Richten
possibly only promising shelter
Exactly.
It's a vital lesson.
Always drill down on the
specifics.
What exactly is being offered or
promised?
What are the limitations?
Assuming a dry roof means no
giant spiders or vengeful
ghosts, Well, they learned the
hard way that's wrong.
Define your safety parameters.
Good one.
OK, nugget 2.
Know your toolkit.
And adapt instantly.
We saw physical weapons fail
utterly against the ghosts.
The party didn't just keep
swinging, they recognized
failure and pivoted.
Traxador went to divine power.
Radley used magic against the
scarecrows strength opened the
door.
So it's not just.
Having different tools.
It's the speed of recognizing
tool as and working and
switching immediately to tool B
or C.
That analytical pivot under
pressure is crucial.
Success depends on that.
Rapid adaptation makes sense.
And Nugget 3 victory.
Has cost beyond golden glory.
They walked out of Arsene fossil
with four potions of
invulnerability.
Amazing treasure, right?
Absolutely game.
Changing, but look at the.
Price Radley nearly died twice.
Critical healing spells gone,
massive psychological fatigue
that forced to retreat even
after getting treasure.
So measure your success not just
by the loot, but by what you had
to spend to get it, physically,
magically, and mentally.
Sometimes the cost is too high
even if you win.
That brings us.
Back to Radley, doesn't it?
He paid the highest personal
cost inside and then got that,
that coffin waiting outside,
right that.
Recurring motif, his full name
expertly carved, it suggests his
story.
His personal journey is marked
now by fate.
Maybe, or by a very specific
intelligent enemy who is
stalking him.
The Manor tested the whole
group.
The coffin singled him out.
It wasn't a.
General beware Arjun Vostholt
sign.
It was Radley full thorn.
We're coming for you.
Exactly.
A personalized promise of future
doom.
Which leads us to the final
thought, The thing to really
chew on.
The session ends with them
retreating, fleeing towards
perceived safety at the Wizards
of Wine Vineyard.
Unknown location run by
potential allies given the level
of threat they just faced.
Personalized, intelligent,
capable of tracking them and
leaving that coffin.
Does heading towards a known
populated location actually make
them safer?
Or does it just make them a more
visible, more concentrated
target for this enemy who
clearly knows Radley's name and
is actively preparing his
demise?
So running to Sanctuary might
actually be like painting a
bigger target on their backs.
Especially Radley's.
It's a chilling.
Possibility, isn't it?
They escaped the haunted house,
yes, but they might have just
stepped out of the frying pan
into a fire being prepared
specifically for one of them.
Their chosen sanctuary could
just be the next stop on a
dungeons and.
Dragons session that nearly took
out a whole party at Argenvest
Holt.
So you've got this group of four
adventurers, right?
You're a horn, the beastmaster,
Radley the warrior mage type,
Traxidor the cleric, and Derm on
the sneaky rogue.
They decided to check out this,
you know, really ruined manner,
and it basically turned into a
massive fight for survival
against spiders, ghosts, the
whole deal.
First off, they kind of learned
that just hitting things hard
doesn't always cut it down in
the ballroom.
Radley, he's their main fighter,
gets jumped by 9 huge like horse
sized spiders.
Seriously, he got tangled up in
silk, poisoned, nearly died
right there.
It took both Traxador and
Orihorn using pretty much all
their emergency healing magic
just to keep him breathing.
close call.
Second, things got even Wilder.
Upstairs, a Stonewall just pops
into existence, trapping them.
Then bam, spectral soldiers
attack and get this, their
regular weapons just went right
through them, pretty much
useless, so they had to switch
gears, right?
Tracidor used his holy powers to
scare most of the undead off,
and Radley had to rely on spells
like Firebolt to take down the
rest.
Magic definitely saved the day
there.
Finally, after finding some
really nice loot, 4 potions of
invulnerability, they managed to
get out of the Manor.
But waiting outside an empty
coffin, perfectly carved with
Radley's full name on it.
Super creepy.
After another tough fight with
some animated scarecrows that
used up their last spells, they
decided OK, this place is way
too dangerous.
They bailed on our genvestolt
and headed E hoping the Wizards
of Wine Vineyard would be safer.
So.
Yeah, this whole bloody mess
really hammered home that
sometimes you got to know when
to run, and the trouble seems to
follow.
Our focus today?
Well, it's drawn from the pretty
harrowing events of Session 22.
Specifically, we're detailing a
party's renewed, and I have to
say, highly dangerous
exploration of the ruined manner
of Arjun Volstold.
After being a previously
repelled, the adventurers
plunged back in only to face
this rapid succession of really
specialized, life threatening
encounters.
I mean everything from 9
enormous spiders to spectral
soldiers, ultimately culminating
in what looks like a
strategically forced retreat.
And the central tension we see
here, I think it's pretty
foundational, isn't it?
It's about successful resource
management and survival in
environments like this manner,
environments built on complex
diversified threats.
Exactly.
So the core question becomes,
should the party have
prioritized direct physical
confrontation?
You know, relying on raw
strength and Marshall skill as
their main tool for resolving
things.
Or were non physical methods,
healing magic, spiritual power,
maybe even specialized avoidance
tactics?
Were those the true necessary
mechanisms for their survival,
for just staying alive?
Right.
I'll be arguing that direct
physical engagement and and
really the application of raw
strength that followed these
were the absolutely critical
turning points.
They resolved the immediate
conflicts and ultimately enabled
the party's eventual extraction.
See, I think.
That approach only tells half
the story because those physical
actions, while yeah, maybe they
initiated conflicts, they
simultaneously LED directly to
immediate life threatening
injury and frankly catastrophic
resource depletion.
So I maintain that the non
physical methods, very specific
healing protocols, spiritual
power designed specifically to
circumvent those ethereal
defenses and strategic avoidance
maneuvers, those were solely
responsible for the party even
continuing to exist and for
their ultimate necessary and I'd
say rather humbling retreat from
the manner.
Well, I.
Still maintain that the analysis
has to begin with those moments
of decisive action, the most
crucial turning points in this
session.
They involved aggressive
physical commitment, often
enabled by Marshall Force, or
just sheer strength.
Think about the initial survival
against those what, 9 enormous
spiders converging on Radley,
the Eldritch Knight?
His continued existence right
then and there?
It hinged on an immediate,
explosive and fundamentally
physically derived action
casting Thunder Wave.
Now this wasn't merely a spell
in the abstract, it was a
calculated physical blast.
It achieved immediate area
denial, physically throwing back
several spiders, even causing
stones to tumble from the
crumbling walls.
This set UA.
Critical tactical doctrine
really controlled disengagement
through area denial.
It was a necessary proactive
physical commitment to offset
what looked like inevitable
entrotment.
He basically created an
opportunity where none existed
purely through applying force.
Think about the initial survival
against those what, 9 enormous
spiders converging on Radley,
the Eldritch Knight, his
continued existence right then
and there.
It hinged on an immediate,
explosive and fundamentally
physically derived action.
And this theme, it resurfaces
later, doesn't it?
When the party gets trapped by
that magically appearing wall in
the East West corridor?
Investigation led by Derman.
It failed.
He concluded the doors to the
turrets were just stuck or
barred, so intellectual or
magical inquiry alone it
couldn't solve the block.
But then it was Radley, who's
explicitly described as a man of
tremendous physical strength,
who just put his shoulder to the
door and forced his way through
with that loud, splintering
crack.
This forceful action was the
only immediate path to freedom,
and it allowed them to find
those crucial potions of
invulnerability before that
magical wall vanished.
The episode seems to demonstrate
that physical capacity can serve
as a kind of universal key,
sometimes circumventing
challenges that subtlety just
couldn't touch in the moment.
OK, but.
That analysis, I feel it
minimizes the cost of that
commitment and misunderstands
what actually secured Radleys
life in that first instance.
The spider encounter itself is,
for me, the perfect illustration
of the systemic failure you risk
when you rely purely on physical
proximity and aggression.
Radley was nearly killed by his
approach.
Let's be clear, he was bitten
several times, then caught in
the silk, collapsed, overcome by
the spider's poison, and
actually stopped breathing after
the second bite.
His physical action LED directly
to immediate collapse.
Survival was entirely contingent
on powerful, rapid non physical
intervention.
Yes OK, Diarmon physically
dragged him fine.
But the core life saving
sequence that was purely
restorative magic deployed by
Traxxor the cleric first spare
the dying, then cure wounds, and
then a second cure wounds
specifically needed to restore
him from stopped breathing.
This sequence moved him from
literally dying to stabilized,
and even then the subsequent
prayer of healing was needed
just to bolster the party enough
to compare them to flee.
So physical engagement created
the crisis.
Non physical specialized
restorative magic ensured they
live to find the next room.
If we define successes, you
know, continuing to exist, then
the magic, not the initial
blast, was a successful factor
here, but that.
Perspective.
Crandev assumes stasis, doesn't
it?
If Radley hadn't used the
Thunder Wave to create that
space, that initial breathing
room, would there have even been
time for Truxador to intervene
with Spare the Dying?
I suspect he would have been
instantly mobbed and killed
before the cleric could even
react.
That initial physical blast was
the necessary precursor, the
tactical pivot that transitioned
the group from what looked like
instantaneous annihilation to
OK, yes, a manageable resource
crisis.
Furthermore, the.
Fight itself demanded
engagement, didn't it?
Yurihorn the Ranger and Dearman
the Eldritch Knight.
They both engaged using arrows.
Tracidor used sacred Flame in a
spiritual weapon.
This sustained direct offensive
force, whether physical arrows
or magically manifested weapons,
it was necessary to call those 9
attackers and make sure the
downed Radley wasn't just, you
know, finished off by the
remaining spiders.
The crisis was resolved by the
application of direct force
period.
I'm still not convinced by that
line of reasoning because you
seem to be focusing on the
initiation rather than the
stabilization.
Isn't the core issue here one of
risk assessment?
Radley's immediate physical
action arguably needlessly
created a near fatal resource
crisis.
A crisis that required 3
specialized magical
interventions just to stabilize
him.
His approach immediately drained
the cleric of critical spell
slots.
Slots that, well, they might
have been absolutely necessary
later to face some truly
insurmountable threat, right?
And what did the party choose to
do immediately after this near
death experience once they
realized the spider chase was
abandoned?
Did they press their advantage
physically?
No.
Yuri Horne Deranger immediately
cast Pass without a trace.
This non physical stealth
tactic, Well, it strongly
suggests the party, having been
brought right to the brink
internally recognized that their
future survival depended heavily
on avoidance and subtlety,
precisely because direct
physical confrontation in those
confined spaces had been so
devastatingly costly.
I.
Acknowledge that pass without a
trace was employed, Yes.
It reflects a temporary tactical
shift, I'll grant that, but one
must remember that stealth only
grants avoidance.
It doesn't resolve existing
threats, and it certainly
doesn't secure necessary
resources.
They.
Still needed physical resolution
to secure their objectives.
Which conveniently brings us
directly to the spectral
soldiers confrontation and that
magical wall.
Ah yes, the spectral soldiers,
which for me provided the
clearest evidence that physical
reliance is fundamentally A
strategic dead end.
In this specific manner, the
party immediately confirmed that
their Marshall efforts failed.
Their weapons were just passing
through the enemies without
effect.
The physical approach wasn't
just ineffective, it was
useless.
Survival here was secured only
when Tracidor used Channel
Divinity, A purely spiritual,
non physical effect, causing all
but one phantom to flee.
And then when Dareman and Radley
reflexively tried swinging
weapons again at the fleeing
undead.
What happened?
Tracidor had to explicitly
reproach them, warn them that
attacking the rebuked undead
could actually break the
spiritual compulsion,
potentially bringing all 7
phantoms right back into the
fight.
This confirms, doesn't it, that
physical aggression against the
specialized ethereal threats was
not just ineffective, but
actively counterproductive and
potentially disastrous.
The right solution was
spiritual, not Marshall.
That's a.
Compelling argument regarding
the spiritual nature of those
specific threats, and I
absolutely grant that Channel
Divinity was the optimal means
of, well, removing the majority
of the combatants.
However, that line of reasoning
ignores the crucial next step in
their exploration, doesn't it?
While the initial.
Physical attacks failed against
those ethereal targets.
The party still needed physical
methods to secure their ultimate
escape from that corridor.
They were trapped by a magical
wall, described as as solid and
unyielding as the rest of the
corridor.
As we already established, it
required Radley's physical
strength, that immense, forceful
shove to break open the door to
the turret chambers.
The party found themselves
facing a kind of binary choice.
Wait around and risk the wall
disappearing, maybe with The
Phantoms potentially returning,
or rely on sheer muscle right
then and there.
While the initial physical
attacks failed against those
ethereal targets, the party
still needed physical methods to
secure their ultimate escape
from that corridor.
They were trapped by a magical
wall, described as as solid and
unyielding as the rest of the
corridor.
As we already established, it
required Radley's physical
strength, that immense, forceful
shove to break open the door to
the tort chambers.
The party found themselves
facing a kind of binary choice.
Physical strength provided the
means to circumvent the barrier,
and that led directly to the
discovery of the four potions of
invulnerability.
That resource acquisition was a
tangible physical reward for
physically forcing open the
exit.
Physicality in this specific
instance proved to be the master
key against an otherwise
impenetrable magical
obstruction.
OK, but.
You're celebrating the discovery
of the potions without really
addressing why they were so
desperately needed at that
point.
They needed those potions
precisely because they were
physically and magically
depleted, largely due to the
earlier reliance on brute force
against the spiders.
The spectral soldier encounter
merely emphasized that they were
in many ways operating with the
wrong tools for this particular
environment.
And let's look at the immediate
aftermath of dealing with those
spectral soldiers.
Even though one phantom
remained, how was it dispatched
by the cleric and the Eldritch
Knight?
Using spells?
Direct targeted magic, not
physical slashes.
This further reinforces the idea
that force had to be channelled
non marshally to be effective
against the manor's primary
defense mechanisms.
It feels like the party learned
the lesson repeatedly.
Physical engagement often equals
injury and depletion, but that.
Depletion, I'd argue, was
managed and overcome through
decisive action.
The party's decision to leave
Argenvastholtz and head towards
the Wizards of Wine.
I see that as a pragmatic Joyce
following successive
accomplishments.
Spiders defeated, phantoms
banished.
And importantly, the finding of
substantial new resources in
those potions.
This wasn't just a panicked
flight, it reads more like a
strategic withdrawal with the
clear goal of resting and
integrating their newly acquired
resources.
Their.
Subsequent.
Survival out in the harsh
environment outside Argenville's
Holt on Day 17 seems to confirm
that direct force remained A
foundational asset.
Their successful defense against
the animated Scarecrows relied
on combining Marshall strength
with targeted offensive spells.
The Tech specifically notes that
Radley's Fireball was
particularly effective, setting
several attackers ablaze and
ensuring a swift, decisive
victory.
Disciplined.
Physically grounded watches
demonstrating a kind of mastery
over their immediate
surroundings which was necessary
for recovery.
The ability to defend themselves
directly enabled their safe rest
and recovery.
I have to.
Disagree entirely with that
characterization of mastery.
The narrative context to me
suggests a forced retreat under
extreme anxiety.
The party explicitly stated they
were still depleted even despite
having achieved a long rest.
They only left the mansion after
recognizing it clearly lurks
with danger, a statement pretty
clearly fueled by the preceding
trauma.
And you have the encounter with
the spectral soldiers, plus that
bizarre discovery of the empty
coffin carved with Radley
Folthorn's name, suggesting
future peril directly related to
him.
That's certainly heightened
their wariness.
They ultimately fled eastward
toward the Wizards of Wine,
actively seeking refuge and
shelter to reorganize, not
because they felt they had
conquered the area.
And while, yes, the scarecrow
fight was a success, it came at
a high cost, didn't it?
It served mainly to confirm
their depleted state.
The text notes that the
engagement expended the party's
few remaining spells, meaning
the direct approach again pushed
them towards a resource crisis.
This mandated the need for
refuge rather than enabling some
kind of renewed offensive.
Their continued existence seems
to rely heavily on judicious use
of spells and the subsequent
avoidance of further conflict
with the main threats back at
the Manor.
The evidence.
However, I think consistently
points toward the necessity of
proactive commitment, of doing
something in every moment of
really existential peril,
whether it's escaping immediate
death with that physical blast
from Thunder Wave, physically
breaking open locked chambers to
gain critical resources, or
decisively fighting off the
final Scarecrow.
Micro's direct, decisive, and
often physical action was the
mechanism.
It's how the party created
space, eliminated immediate
threats, or secured their
objectives.
Physical strength and direct
offensive force provided
necessary resolution to these
existential threats, especially
when non committal subtlety or,
you know, intellectual analysis
failed to provide a timely exit.
The lesson seems to be that
sometimes you simply must be the
irresistible force.
I frame it differently.
I think the core narrative of
session 22 is really one of
necessary humility regarding
physical capacity.
The party was repeatedly
battered, nearly destroyed by
physical means.
Their survival depended
fundamentally on retreat, on
precise non physical healing
magic, those restorative
interventions that literally
stabilized the dying man, and
crucial non physical abilities
like Channel Divinity and Past
Without a Trace.
The manor's specialized complex
defenses demanded finesse and
careful resource management, not
brute force to prevent utter
collapse.
The group survived, I think, by
recognizing when to stop being
the irresistible force and
instead adopt maybe.
The path of.
Water finding the way around and
I think.
Both perspectives, really.
They reveal profound lessons
about confronting unknown
dangers within these ruins.
The material demonstrates pretty
clearly that a successful
outcome for this specific group
often relies on a very delicate
balance, recognizing precisely
when to commit to strength to
force an opening, and then when
to rely on subtlety and
restorative magic to manage the
inevitable fallout.
Indeed.
This material offers some
fascinating insight into how
different highly specialized
threats require entirely
different tool sets, doesn't it?
And how easily that strategic
balance can shift between
needing immediate aggressive
action and needing immediate
avoidance.
The true genius of the session
might actually lie in their
ability to adapt and change
their doctrine midstream
session.
Report about exploring the very
dangerous arguing Vostholt
manner which led to some close
calls and a decision to pull
back.
Yeah.
Diving straight in this document
really throws you into the
action.
High stakes from the get go.
Absolutely.
It sets up this deadly
environment and the party is
constantly, you know, pushed to
their limits.
It really is.
But to make that tension hit
even harder, we need to think
about where the reader gets a
moment to breathe, and where
maybe things move a bit too fast
past some really key character
moments.
Exactly.
The fights are immediate,
they're visceral, really well
done, spot on.
But let's start with that ending
bit outside the Manor.
Super chilling, right?
The.
Party gets out of Argon
Vostholt, and there's this wagon
driver who's left?
Well, a message.
An empty coffin with Radley
Folthorn's name carved on it.
Oh yeah.
It's a huge hook, really
shocking personal threat and
that brings.
Us straight to our first point.
The profound dramatic reveal of
the empty coffin named for
Radley Folthorn, warrants
greater narrative space and
lingering emotional reflection.
Yeah.
The weakness here is really
about the pacing and the focus.
Right at that moment, the
narrative almost treats this
incredibly personal kind of
existential threat.
Like finding, I don't know, some
healing potions, right?
It moves.
So quickly from finding his name
on a coffin to the practical
stuff.
Okay, let's camp set watches it.
Just sort.
Of minimizes the immediate
emotional weight, doesn't it?
It really.
Does and think about Radley's
perspective here.
He just survived, nearly dying
twice inside.
Yeah, Webbed.
Up collapsed, needed
stabilizing, gets bitten again
the second he wakes up and then
he.
Steps outside and sees that his
own name expertly carved.
That psychological gut punch
gets kind of brushed aside by
the quick move to just setting
up Camp the reader.
Needs to feel that shock, that
shift.
The danger just went from being
inside the ruins very immediate
to something cold, calculated
and following them.
So the suggestion.
Is pretty straightforward.
Slow down the pacing right
around discovering and opening
that coffin.
Exactly.
Really maximize the horror, the
uncertainty.
Make the Reaver sit with that
dread for a moment.
And we need some.
Concrete ways to really ground
that feeling.
You mentioned the expertly done
carving earlier.
Yes, Lean.
Into that, describe the coffin
itself.
Is it new, Old, covered in fresh
grave dirt?
That detail expert carving hints
at someone intelligent watching
them planning this.
It makes the threat feel less
random, more focused on Radley.
OK.
So emphasize the physical
details.
What else then?
Maybe include a moment of just
intense focus purely on Radley's
reaction right when he sees his
name.
Ah, like.
Contrasting his physical power,
he just smashed open those
turret doors, right with this
sudden like psychological
vulnerability.
Precisely.
Him facing the silent tailor
made threat makes sense.
And the decision to camp detail
the conversation.
Make it crystal clear that
finding the coffin is the
trigger for hunkering down
immediately, not just General.
Oh, it's dangerous here, right?
It's not.
Just weariness.
It's this specific thing forces
their hand into a defensive
posture right then and there
because this threat is now
mobile and it's pointed at one
of them.
Yeah.
That contrast you mentioned
strength versus vulnerability,
that's potent stuff.
So if the.
Coffin is this personalized
external threat.
The report also shows the party
wrestling with internal
pressures, too.
I mean, all those tactical
withdrawals.
Fleeing the revenants, backing
out after hearing that hissing
sound.
Yeah, the account.
Tells us what they did.
They left repeatedly, but we're
kind of missing the why
sometimes the internal debate
that led to hitting the eject
button and that's.
Exactly our second critique,
clarifying the party's
motivations and internal debate
during moments of tactical
withdrawal, which strengthen the
overall narrative logic and
character agency.
The weakness.
Is that these key decisions,
like leaving the bedroom with
the soft Serpentine hissing or
switching focus from the north
side to the upper floors because
Orihorn suggested it?
They feel a bit like plot points
handed down.
Yeah, like.
Feta complete.
We know they're scared generally
but not always.
Why they chose that specific
moment to stop pushing forward
it.
Feels like we might be losing a
chance for character insight if
we only focus on the action of
running away totally.
Agree.
So the suggestion here is to
weave in just brief sharp bits
of dialogue, or maybe stated
reasons just enough to anchor
why they shifted tactics,
especially when things felt
ambiguous or scary like hearing.
Their thought process, or maybe
a quick hushed argument?
Exactly.
For instance, remember after
they fought those spectral
soldiers, they started
questioning Van Richten's whole
Argenvas told is safe claim.
Oh yeah.
That's a perfect spot, right?
So detail that reevaluation.
Was the idea that he maybe just
meant shelter and didn't promise
safety something they all agreed
on?
Or was someone maybe tracks it
or pushing back showing that?
Debate would frame why they're
so cautious later, making the
next retreat feel more earned
precisely.
And what about those more
ambiguous threats, like the
hissing?
That's pure uncertainty making
them bolt.
Yeah.
How do you?
Show the why there well for
that.
Bedroom withdrawal?
Maybe specify why the hissing
suddenly made them fearful of
any further encounters.
Was it just the sound itself or
did someone maybe whisper?
Sounds like those spiders Or I
can't face another phantom fight
right now.
So connecting the current fear
directly back to a very recent
trauma.
Exactly.
It makes the jumpiness feel
specific, not just general
anxiety.
It mirrors the previous trauma
like you said.
Makes sense?
And Yuri Horn's suggestion to
check the upper floors instead
of the Northside?
That felt a bit abrupt, since
the others were apparently
ambivalent.
Yeah.
That's another spot we need to
know.
What makes the Northside
suddenly unappealing, right?
Then your horn needs to voice a
clear reason to sway the others.
OK, so.
Maybe, he points out, that's
where we saw the Revenants, or
that ballroom looked ready to
collapse.
Let's try upstairs first,
something like.
That give your horn a solid
tactical reason that cuts
through the group's uncertainty,
gives them agency, OK.
Moving on, I have to say the
combat descriptions themselves
are fantastic.
That ballroom scene with Radley
getting webbed, collapsing like
a puppet?
Oh yeah, totally cinematic.
Really sells the danger, but.
And this is the thing.
The recovery afterwards feels a
bit quick, almost summarized.
Compared to the intense detail
of the fight itself.
The ruin doesn't quite match the
recovery.
That's a.
Perfect lead into our final
critique.
While the combat details are
excellently executed, maximizing
the impact requires equally
vivid description of the
immediate physical and emotional
toll on the party following high
stakes engagements.
The weakness.
Then is that the jumps almost
straight to the next action,
casting prayer of healing,
deciding where to go next, right
without.
Giving us, the readers, a moment
to just absorb the exhaustion,
the mess, the state of the room
after everything went down and
that.
Contrast, you know, between the
Super detailed violence and the
kind of quick summary of getting
patched up.
It lessens the long term feeling
of trauma we need to.
Anchor that trauma better.
So the suggestion is simple.
Just spend a little bit more
narrative space describing the
immediate aftermath of those big
fights.
How so?
Link the.
Physical state of the characters
and even their surroundings to
that overall feeling of being
depleted.
The report says they feel
depleted the next morning, but
we need to show why even a long
rest didn't fully cut it.
OK.
Can you?
Give some specific examples.
How do we bring the environment
and that physical toll into the
recovery beat?
Sure.
Like right after Traxidora casts
prayer of healing in the main
hall after the spider fight.
Don't just say the spell was
cast, maybe describe the
lingering tension.
Like what?
Like the?
Sticky feeling of webs still
clinging to their gear, maybe
the horrific sight of the dead
giant spider still slumped in
the doorway, or just the visible
trembling fatigue on Radley and
the others who had to charge in
and cut him loose.
OK, Yeah.
Let the actual mess and chaos of
the fight linger into that quiet
moment.
Exactly.
Residue of combat, as you put
it.
It makes it feel less like a
clean skirmish and more like a
genuinely traumatic event,
right?
It raises the stakes
retroactively, almost.
And another.
Example, after the scarecrow
fight the next morning you
mentioned they felt depleted
despite the rest.
Link that feeling to something
concrete.
Maybe mention lingering aches
from specific hits the day
before, or highlight the
scarcity of remaining spell
slots you mentioned.
Erihorn and Radley had to
scramble for their gear.
Describe that sudden clumsy
panic.
It shows they're still running
on empty even after sleeping.
OK, Connect.
The feeling to tangible
evidence.
And there was.
That great detail during the
fight, the friendly fire moment,
Erihorn's hail of thorns hitting
Radley, Yes.
That's perfect leverage that
that specific tactical mistake,
that moment of friendly fire.
It should echo, even briefly,
how maybe just a momentary
description of the tension
between them right after the
fight ends before they move on,
a quick, sharp glance exchanged.
Or maybe Urihorn offers a gruff,
hasty apology before they pack
up.
Ah.
So showing that the stress isn't
just from the monsters, it's
potentially fraying their own
interactions too.
Exactly.
It reinforces that the trauma
has internal consequences for
the group, not just external
wounds.
OK.
This has been really useful.
So 3 clear areas to focus on to
really elevate this narrative.
Yeah, just.
To recap quickly, first, really
amplify the emotional impact of
those personalized threats,
especially that empty coffin.
Slow the pace right down at the
discovery.
Let the horror land second.
Make sure to show the internal
logic behind the party's
retreats.
Give us the why, the
deliberation, the specific fear
driving their choices, maybe
through quick dialogue snippets
and finally.
Make the aftermath of the fights
as vivid as the fights
themselves.
Anchor the recovery moments in
the physical toll and the messy
environment to really under
score the lasting impact of
these encounters.
Excellent.
Points.
These suggestions offer great
ways to take what's already a
really strong, tense report and
make it even more immersive and
psychologically resonant.
Absolutely.
We genuinely love to see how
these adjustments play out.
Yeah, feel.
Free to work these ideas in and
send the revised version back
our way for another look.